this week and social justice for your
cannibalism you did you hear this about
BuzzFeed I could not hear that about
BuzzFeed you did hear it about buzz I
did not get you it has to cue this up
people got mad at BuzzFeed accusing them
of being racist for doing this video 27
questions for black people the entire
video of course is based on the idea of
stereotyping black people this question
is only directed toward black people so
I know I'm not supposed to answer it but
there was so much buzz see what it is
there's so much buzz about this that I
am a very clever clever okay I'm gonna
do this ready to this I'm gonna answer
all of these questions I know I'm white
but I am going to try and not approach
this from from black white penis
privilege non penis privilege pansexual
and from a logical perspective so stay
with me here let's roll the clips why is
it so hard to be on time
like why does five to ten always become
20 to 30 I I don't find it hard to be on
time at all I don't have a property of a
problem is this are you insinuating this
is a black thing this is a bad start
I suffer from it too
if my dad is on fleek am i lit I don't
know what that means I'm not going to
lie this is probably where the cultural
difference is coming to play let's move
on why is it a problem if I like anime
who says it's who says it's a problem if
you like anime want black people look at
your shoes before they greet you I've
never noticed that maybe I'm just not so
self focused that I'm looking at them
and greeting them I've never noticed
black people always looking at my shoes
and if I did it really wouldn't bother
me that much I love shoes you and Dick
Morris moving on why are we more likely
to engage in the new dance trend and
then we already get involved in politics
or opening a business I don't know
that's a good question maybe you should
ask the executives at BT or the Oprah
network who constantly decide to fill
the market demand with dance programs as
opposed to those regarding politics or
opening businesses I guess how did
watermelon become our thing like
everybody should love watermelon this
one's fairly straightforward I'll be at
an ugly history it goes back to southern
slaves tied in with southern culture
where watermelon was very common also
what's delicious why do you get upset
what I don't like black celebrity I I
don't I don't get upset I don't think
anybody gets upset if you like a black
celebrity are you implying that all
black people get upset if you don't like
every black celebrity that seems a
little bit racist except for Denzel if
you don't like Denzel you should be
jailed just like Bill Nye wants to do
with climate change skeptics race aside
some people are just terrible that
wasn't a question but agree what do we
call each other the n-word but get
vehemently upset when a white person
uses the n-word I've been wondering that
myself funny you should bring it up I
wanted to bring it up but if I do I lose
my job it drains my soul to hear the
word and I just don't understand how
people who have any understanding of
history can use that word I would agree
that people who have no understanding of
history are probably most likely to use
that word as many of you seen in this
video draining your soul sounds like a
bit much but it's bad you had a question
again you're not getting this
why is my natural hair the hair that
grows out of my head
seen as a political statement first
thank you for specifying the hair that
grows out of
had this could have taken a weird
direction I don't know anybody who
considers it a political statement where
is this coming from I don't know people
who look at my shoes I don't know people
who hate you if you don't like all black
celebrities they don't know people who
see your hair is a political statement
are you tar and feathering all of us
this way or is it just black people do
you hate black people only think people
with white skin looks better than people
with dark skin I don't know that's not a
preset rule nobody hears you said it
you're the only one who said it right
now do you really believe that black is
beautiful or is that just something you
say cuz it sounds cool why do you sound
like we will say that you're pretty for
a dark-skinned girl first off I would
never say that to you for multiple
reasons I also don't know that anybody
uses that buzz phrase some people like
black people some people don't some
people like blonds some people like
brunettes
some people like redheads that's what we
should be talking about that's getting
into fetish territory you ever met
someone who likes a redhead it's creepy
it's unnatural and it's creepy when that
is said to me it still makes me feel
like the ugliest little black thing this
is a statement and why is just thrown
out as a generality it seems very
specific for someone to say you're
pretty good-looking for a black girl why
is this being tossed out to the general
populace also talking about the redheads
earlier
I meant men who like redheads redhead
women are attractive redhead men get the
short end of the stick Casey you know
what I'm talking about
why don't some black men only date white
women statistically that's not true it's
observably untrue why is it okay for
black men to date white women but not
okay for a black woman to date outside
her race I don't know that that's true
you seem to be the one assuming a whole
lot here you're copy-pasting some of
your emotions onto something that's not
statistically observable cause it's time
to plug our corporate overlords
audible.com great service if you go to
audible.com slash Crowder this week you
can download a free audio book it's
great you can listen to audiobooks you
can actually learn something unlike this
video here at BuzzFeed and you can have
it playing on in the background while
you're playing Angry Birds are doing
something else
I recommend this week mark Levins
liberty and tyranny he guides his life
and all human life through the proven
exercise you have to get used to the
voice but it is a great foundational
book and understanding the central
of the federal government versus states
rights audible.com slash Crowder make
sure you go now we continue suffering
through the video
why do you protest black lives matter
and then tear each other down in the
next breath that's a fair question one
that I would direct toward the black
lives matter movement leaders DeRay and
Shawn king who little known fact is not
black await their answer with great
anticipation why do we say that we don't
want to be seen as a monolith but then
try to take people's black cards away
for not liking something that's
supposedly black it's actually a good
point it's not really fair when people
do that with people like Condoleezza
Rice or Herman Cain or dr. Bennett I
don't talk about them why are we so
quick to support a non black owned
business within hesitate when it's a
black owned business that has literally
never entered into the equation when I
go into a business I couldn't care less
if it's a white business or a black
business I only care about good business
as a general rule I don't even know who
runs the business I don't have a
checklist this okay everything else is
good great service cake well buy the
black guy I can't go damn it that's
another one I gotta cross off the list I
mean is there a cut-off time for this
whole homophobia thing in the black
community cuz I'm really looking forward
to that I suspected you were a lesbian
the answer to that one is short probably
not wise growing up without a father so
common in our race actually a very good
question and I would go back to the
previous statement because when the
leaders of the black community like
larry elder or Thomas Sol speak out
against it they get told that they're
not black enough by people like the
social justice warriors at BuzzFeed why
don't we like to confront our mental
health issues therapy is such a
wonderful and magical place seems the
insinuation here is that there is a
disproportionate amount of mentally
unhealthy people in the black community
which I think makes you a racist and I
probably shouldn't address that because
again I could lose my job
why is there a checklist for being black
I don't know again you'd probably have
to ask the pariahs of your community who
are intellectual and try to be very
helpful who you deemed to not be black
enough generally they're more
conservative and big on personal
responsibility
but they're just Uncle Tom's or
something why is being educated
considered a white thing why can't I
love school and also be black it's not
considered a white thing I don't
consider it a white thing if you look at
the grants and affirmative action
scholarships and quotas certainly
academia doesn't see it as a white thing
what are you on about why do I have to
be mixed in order to have long hair what
why do you think well-off black people
don't know what it means to be black I
don't know why don't you ask leaders in
the black community like Al Sharpton or
Jesse Jackson or black lives matter who
tell you that if you're well-off you
don't know what it's like to be black
black isn't only defined by adversity
I don't know again I'm not why do some
black people say oh I have Native
American in my family in order to feel
interesting or more valuable than other
black people around them I have
literally never known any black person
to do that that's probably why you don't
hear a whole lot of jokes on the
Chappelle show
or the latest Chris Rock album about
what's the deal with all these blacks
claiming they're 1/16 Cherokee I think
you just have some deeply rooted
self-esteem issues and you might need to
get down to them because you're
cluttering this whole video yep why
can't we just acknowledge that there are
a bunch of different types of black
people walking around and they're all
amazing and unique and special in their
own way it'd be a lot easier to do if
you didn't just toss out these general
questions as though all black people are
on the same page as you
we within the black community are so
quick to kind of tear each other down
and to look towards other races in terms
of their success and in terms of what
they have but never want to kind of look
into the mirror ourselves
it's either looking to other races or
looking in the mirror one or the other
and again I would go back to black
leadership like the Al Sharpton's of
Jesse Jackson's or Shaun King's that
erase why do they tell you that it's
your job to tear down people like Larry
elder like Thomas ol like Herman Cain I
love black folks but that doesn't mean I
don't have questions questions yeah I
get that I think this video has raised
more questions than it's answered why do
black people look at your shoes before
your face why am I only allowed to grow
my hair long if I'm biracial why is it
seen as a political statement why do I
have
the claim that I'm part Native American
to be cool these are not common threads
that any race is aware of not why people
not black people as seen by the reaction
from the black community to BuzzFeed so
if you're asking these very specific
questions and throwing them out as
generalities and then complaining about
generalities maybe the problem isn't the
black community because not the white
privilige community maybe the problem is
you maybe the problem is your friends
the problem is your friends at BuzzFeed
thanks for watching this free video I
hope you got your money's worth there
are other free videos playing in these
boxes or you can subscribe for free
speaking of free head on over to
audible.com slash Crowder and really
take advantage of the free audiobook
special going on this week not only do
you get to learn something but you get
to support this channel and more free
content and we get to keep the lights on
dammit